guten morgen herr steffel die situation
besonders angespannt werden beate
darüber berichtet viele menschen mussten
die nacht in ihren autos verbringen
jetzt gibt es die warnung vor dem wetter
die straßen nicht zu befahren der
verkehrsminister hat sogar gibt dazu
geraten bis mittwoch ganz zu hause zu
bleiben dennoch trauen sich die menschen
offenbar oder müssen die menschen
offenbar weiter auf die autobahn auf die
straßen wie es ihre einschätzung dazu
einfach das ist die eine seite der
medaille die andere seite der medaille
ist viele leute sind trotzdem nach wie
vor so unterwegs dass sie denken es wird
schon gut gehen das werden wir schon
schaffen was soll denn passieren mein
gott die straßen naja kriegen wir schon
irgendwie hin
und das ist bei solchen wetterlagen bei
sollen also einer verkehrslage wie wir
sie momentan haben das ist leider leider
in irrglaube von daher auch unser appell
noch einmal an alle autofahrer wenn sie
nicht unbedingt müssen dann hören sie
mal auf den verkehrsminister das ist in
dem fall wirklich ein guter rat und
bleiben sie bitte bitte zu hause
man sieht es hier auf der a 1 zwischen
dortmund und hagen auch an den vielen
lkws unterwegs sind hier läuft das
einigermaßen es ist ein bisschen stau
aber nicht sonderlich wild das geht noch
solche situationen wie wir es gerade
gehört haben von bielefeld von der a2
das ist natürlich wirklich ja das ist
der absolute supergau und also schlimmer
geht es halt nicht mehr für autofahrer
wenn eben lkw fahrer unterwegs sind das
sind in dem fall leider die lkw fahrer
die sich dann ein solches verbot was bis
gestern eben galt nicht gehalten haben
dieses unterschätzen die sich dann quer
stellt dann geht einfach nichts mehr das
haben wir gerade gesehen da hilft keine
rettungsgasse da hilft gar nichts und
dann muss man einfach nur warten bis
dann eben rettungskräfte wie das thw
solche lkws weggezogen haben und daher
eben noch einmal unser appell bitte
bitte wenn es irgendwie geht zu hause
bleiben
er schätze sie sprechen die lkws an
unser reporter hat auch berichtet dass
eben immer noch viele lkws auf den
autobahnen unterwegs sind offenbar auch
dort wo es streckenweise sogar ein
fahrverbot gibt wie schätzen sie diese
lage ein
ja das ist natürlich in der
logistikbranche ein mittlerweile
altbekanntes problem da herrscht auch
bei solchen wetter und verkehrslage ein
enormer termindruck die lkw-fahrer die
könnten teilweise gar nicht anders als
zu versuchen weiterzukommen die haben
dann termin fracht an bord oder sonst
irgendwas die kriegen natürlich auch dem
entsprechenden druck dass sie ihre
termine irgendwie halten das ist für die
armen menschen die da vorne im
führerhaus sitzen für die habe ich sogar
verständnis zum teil weil eigentlich
müssten sie sich darüber hinwegsetzen
sagen nein es geht einfach nicht aber da
herrscht ein enormer druck gerade in
dieser branche und deswegen sieht man
das dann auf den straßen es wird
versucht man denkt eben kommen irgendwie
schaffen wir das aber ein lkw mit diesem
gewicht mit dieser größe wenn er auch
nur ein bisschen eis erwischt dann steht
der so schnell quer so schnell kann man
halt einfach nicht gucken und das wird
immer wieder unterschätzt und deswegen
haben wir dann da so große probleme
auch da eben der appell an die
lkw-fahrer ich kann verstehen da ist ein
großer druck irgendwie zu versuchen
durch zu kommen
aber bitte bitte auch hier erst mal
stehen bleiben durchatmen und versuchen
so eine situation dann auch doch mal
abzuwarten wenn es irgendwie geht
wie schwierig gestaltet sich denn
derzeit die arbeit des adac es wenn
menschen eher auf der auto übernachten
müssen in ihren autos wenn es zu
zahlreichen glätte und auffahrunfällen
kommt was bedeutet das für den adac für
ihren einsatz dort vor ort ja ist
natürlich auch für uns eine
extremsituation
wir hatten gestern früh im berufsverkehr
im schnitt 600 anrufe pro stunde von
menschen die hilfe brauchten nur in
nordrhein westfalen
das ist also schon eine ganze menge und
wenn es dann so aussieht wie jetzt
teilweise auf der a2 dass unsere
abschleppdienste unsere pannenhelfer
wenn die selber gar nicht durchkommen
dann ist das natürlich ein noch viel
größeres problem weil wenn man hilfe
leisten möchte das aber nicht schafft
ist das natürlich sehr deprimierend auch
für uns ansonsten ist es so dass wir
natürlich den menschen versuchen zu
helfen so gut es eben geht manchmal
kommen wir nicht durch momentan haben
wir meistens in der wartezeit von fast
einer stunde das ist lang wenn man auf
hilfe wartet natürlich nicht so lang wie
die ganze nacht im
zu verbringen und deswegen versuchen wir
auch alles ich kann das vielleicht
einmal ganz kurz aus eigener erfahrung
leider erzählen vor 20 jahren 2001 saß
ich auch auf der a 3 eine ganze nacht
lang mal fest damals habe ich noch
studiert wird mit einem kommilitonen
nach hause gefahren wir kamen halt
ungefähr 100 kilometer weit und dann
ging nichts mehr
und das ist wirklich das ist
erschreckend im ersten moment vor allem
wenn man sieht es passiert nichts
überhaupt nichts und die meisten
menschen sind eben auch darauf nicht
vorbereitet waren wir damals auch nicht
werden auch keine decken im auto und
irgendwann ist man halt auch wirklich
echt angefressen weil man denkt es
müsste doch jetzt jemand kommen und
helfen das kann doch nicht sein
aber da auch noch mal für die menschen
die da stehen ja das ist schlimm aber
glauben sie mir
jeder der irgendwie in sachen hilfe
unterwegs ist der versucht auch so
schnell wie möglich zu helfen
was glauben sie wenn wir in den heutigen
tag schauen und auch in die darauf
folgenden tage dieser woche worauf
müssen wir uns wohl noch einstellen
also wenn wir uns die wetterlage so
angucken und wenn es teilweise nachts
von minus zwölf grad kaltes und das soll
ja so bleiben dann ist eine entspannung
nicht wirklich in sicht irgendwann wenn
der schneefall vielleicht mal ein
bisschen weniger wird dann kriegt man es
auch hin dass die räumdienste die
straßen dauerhaft frei kriegen aber
trotzdem kann es nachts natürlich eben
nochmal zu glätte kommen wenn es eben so
kalt ist und die straßen tagsüber
vielleicht sogar wenn die sonne mal
rauskommt ein bisschen anschauen
nachts wird es dann wieder spiegelglatt
also von daher ist nach wie vor absolute
vorsicht oder das gebot der stunde
jeder der mit dem auto unterwegs sein
muss muss wirklich ganz ganz vorsichtig
fahren viel zeit einplanen und ja sich
am besten so gut es geht vorbereiten
oder eben wenn es irgendwie geht zu
hause bleiben also deswegen ist wird die
nächsten tage jetzt noch nicht so viel
besser
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren